[Music]
on today's show we talk
all about family difficulties how to
grieve
how to share expectations and what
happens when you have to sacrifice what
you want to do
in order to take care of those that you
love this is a good one stay tuned
[Music]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john deloney show
we talk about your life your mental
health your relationships
grief struggling whatever is going on in
your life let me know how i can help
we're here to walk alongside you as we
all figure this out
together give me a shout at
1-844-693-3291 if you want to be on the
show
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask johndaloney.com
ask and we have big exciting news on
today's show
james provided the lyrics of the day
so if you want to see what's going on in
that guy's head just hang on
just hang on at the end of the show
you're going to find out
and by the i cannot kick this cold
i feel like my face is going to blow up
see i thought it was allergies
what's the difference well one can get
all of us sick and one can't
oh i've got allergies everybody
allergies you mean through the
through the 18 panes of glass
thanks for caring about me james i put
some medicine on your desk
just going to use some essential oils
and end up in the er again like an idiot
oh man this is deloney after dark
we're for sure doing this and
hey i think james and kelly can we do
this
we need to have a show that is just
going to be all positive
it's going to be all about puppies and
hope
happiness we're not gonna have any
callers because we don't get those
wrong show we are we're gonna have an
all happy show
it's gonna be called the sunshine hour
with john delony
what are we gonna talk about good stuff
all right let's go to
kurt in san antonio texas hey kurt
what's up man
hey john uh how are you doing today i'm
doing all right brother how are you
well to quote uh an associate of yours
better than i deserve
outstanding outstanding so what's up man
how can i help
well to be brief about it john um i have
been forced by circumstances uh to
become a caregiver for my elderly mother
and
her special needs daughter who's also my
sister and to be honest with you
um i feel trapped and uh resentful at
the same time and yet i'm mad at myself
for harboring those feelings so
uh yeah it's kind of a self-fulfilling
prophecy i guess
that's exactly right man so you say
you're
forced to tell me about that well i mean
nobody's holding a gun to my head
obviously but
um you know i have a moral compass and
nobody else can
render the necessary aid and i'm the
only one in a position to do so so i
feel compelled by
my morality to help and i'm i'm not mad
about it not by morality let's change
all that words
all that that talk force
let's say you're a person of character
and you're making this choice and the
choice is hard
and it's not sunshine and rainbows
but you're choosing to do this is that
fair
i mean i suppose so yes morality is
is some existential philosophical
concept
it's not forcing you to do anything
you're choosing to be a person of moral
character
which i applaud i think it's awesome
and so you're choosing this and i think
that's really noble and great
and i can help you with that but i want
to shift out of the victim language
right okay is that fair
i mean i i'm not the expert here so i
i'm going to defer to
uh to your expertise in this regard all
right so let's change the language
around and say man i'm a person of
character
i'm gonna take care of my mom i'm gonna
take care of my special needs sister
and tell me what it's like how long you
been doing this
what's what are the needs for for your
mom and your sister
so it all started about a year ago with
the onset of kohit
um they're both elderly and i didn't
know
uh whether or not they would stand the
chance that they got the disease
and so i told them hey look i'll do all
of your shopping for you
whatever you need text me i'll get it
for you and we had a whole
system of sanitation that we did
so that no pathogens could possibly get
inside so
originally it was just a logistical
support role because you know at the
time we didn't know what we were dealing
with
right as time progressed you know we got
more and more information about the
disease and said okay well maybe it's
not as bad as everybody's saying so we
began to relax a little bit but then
um we had a stroke of bad luck uh her
partner
um went became gravely ill really
quickly like within 48 hours her partner
went from just not feeling well
to being brain dead your mom
yes her partner yes their partner uh
basically died within the span of 72
hours
oh man i'm sorry unexpected so i
stayed out and i just kind of moved in
temporarily and just helped her with a
grief and i'm
i'm no mental health professional i've
got my own demons but
i knew that i needed to get help so i
tried to sign her up for some of those
online counseling sessions and they kind
of worked to some extent but
at the end of the day i think she just
grew tired of it yeah um how long is she
with this
how long was she with this person oh
about two years
okay two years so i mean it's not like
they were lifelong partners but she's
you know she really enjoyed their
company um yeah then after that she
needed to have
um a very invasive surgery which
required a
very extensive therapeutic regimen so i
stayed and guided her through the
surgery and i did all the therapy you
know i had to go from loving son to mean
drill sergeant for
you know two hours a day
and of course i was taking care of the
house i was
keeping everything clean keeping
everybody fed
she has four animals so i had to clean
up after them as well which i don't mind
doing it it's really not
that hard objectively what do you do for
a living man
so i actually graduated about a year ago
from an apprenticeship and
it was a five-year apprenticeship and
doing what um
uh doing construction okay um it's a
skilled trade i don't
know how specific you want me to be no
that's cool that helps
but i it's something i invested a lot of
time uh
and trouble then and uh you know because
i want to be debt-free and i want to
follow dave ramsey's plan
sure and that was a long thing but
anyway
i felt like i had to sacrifice a year of
my life to help and in the long scheme
of things i think
i'm gonna take my last breath knowing
that i did the good and moral thing but
i don't know i i just feel i just feel
burdened i feel like i don't get to live
my own life because
you know i other people need me you know
what i mean and that's a very selfish
thing to be honest but
yeah i just don't know what to make of
this are you married
no i'm not how old are you um i am 34.
okay
how old is your sister my sister
is 22 years my senior so she is
uh 56.
so you came along 22 years after your
sister
yeah my entire family tree is really uh
it's really uh that's a separate issue
but yeah
that'd be a whole other call that's that
sounds fascinating and so what is your
care responsibilities for her
really my care responsibilities for her
are just feeding her
um you know making sure she has her
medicine she's really easy
to care for so i i don't know why i'm
bellyaching about it but
it's just the knowledge that as of right
now i
i have to stay and care for her when i
uh you know want to go out and do all
these things i want to travel to other
places work in other places now that i
have this job i can
get a job anywhere in the united states
with better wages and better conditions
but
stay here so here's the deal man what if
i told you just to go
i've got my professional expertise this
sucks for you man just
move tell your mom i'm out i got a
cool new thing i'm gonna move and i'm
gonna get out of here
i've spent a year with you guys um
uh i've worked really hard but i'm out
feel good about that i could do that
yeah i could do that yeah
what's stopping you from doing that i
guess just to know
just the idea that somehow i would be
betraying my family you know i
i don't have a large family and we're
very small and
here's the thing here's the thing
brother you've backed yourself into some
weird corner and i don't know why you're
doing this to yourself
you've made it this either or world
either i'm gonna go do what i want to do
and live my life
and get to use my professional talents
and be a scumbag in the process or
i'm gonna take care of my mom and my
sister and everything i love and care
about is just gonna go to crap
and i'm just gonna have to be a martyr
and i'm gonna die knowing i did the
right thing but my life sucked
yeah that's kind of how it seems yeah
why are you doing that to yourself
i mean i don't know i i guess
i guess my experience is such that i
could only discern reality by those two
extremes
well i want to offer you a third option
man the third option is this
anybody with their salt and with the
financial ability helps their mo
their elderly mother out especially in
the middle of a pandemic
and millions of people have to work
alongside their special needs brothers
and sisters
i've spent my career working with
special needs folks um
folks with special needs better say that
um it's hard
and it's labor intensive and it's
exhausting
and you choose the attitude that you
bring to that
do i want to go and see this person as a
burden as a beating or am i going to
look at this as this sacrifice and
commitment and know more
about connection and love than anybody
else on planet earth
that's the choice you get to bring to it
but right now you're showing up at these
things doing what you think
and believe to be right and you're
bringing a cup of poison with you and
just taking shots of it all day
is there anybody else is there anybody
else in this
in y'all's ecosystem that can help while
you go build up your career because at
some point you got to go make money
right yeah is your unless your mom's
independently wealthy and you're
you're a millionaire now no no that's
that's
that's not the case okay at some point
you got to go make money
right exactly um in the community you
live in is
it just can you not get a job in
construction where you live
i can no i i actually had to quit my job
recently because
right now i need to care for my mom
right now but here's the thing
and maybe i should have mentioned this
earlier i'm only going to be needed in
this capacity mate just for another
couple of months
uh because it's it have you heard the
aphorism when it rains it pours
of course uh we've just had one
major medical emergency after another
that
i believe necessitated me taking a
sabbatical from work to
help care for my family and hey listen
listen right stop right there
it you've experienced trauma on top of
trauma on top of trauma
and i wish my hope for you brother is
that you can exhale
and say thank god i'm in a position to
take a sabbatical from work and take
care of my family
what a gift and i had some dreams
and they're gonna be put on pause for a
second but i get to take care of my
family
dude you can choose it's gonna sound
crazy
you can choose optimism or you can
choose
pessimism that's a choice it's a daily
practice
and the more you choose pessimism the
more likely your body is to revolt
against you
you're going to end up with your
shoulder slumped over and your head
ducked down and you're going to resent
the very people you feel compelled to
take care of
yeah that sounds like a recipe for
toxicity
it is and you're just mainlining it
right now
well you're right i mean obviously
that's why i'm calling you i just
is it such a simple thing as i'd need to
change my paradigm
as i just need to change the way i'm
thinking do i just need to say to myself
the mantra
i'm blessed to be in a position to be
able to help my family or
that's that's part that's part of it
that's a start
but it also you've got to begin to take
care of yourself
and that means you're going gonna have
to move your body you're gonna have to
go exercise
that's one of the number one start
starting lines for people who are stuck
in trauma and depression and people who
are caught in a negative thought loop
and a negative action loop in a negative
behavior loop
just go move your body you got to start
taking care of yourself
something i do i actually listen to uh
to your podcast while i do my daily joke
that's outstanding so add weights to it
do something a little bit different
shake it up for yourself
okay okay um be intentional about having
other people around do you have friends
do you hang out with other people um
you know not anymore a lot of my friends
have moved away so i'm kind of
stuck here well not stuck i'm isolated
relatively there you go
all right so now it's time it's on you
go find some friends
i don't care where you do it how you do
it if you got to get a babysitter for
your sister
i don't care you got to go be with other
people okay
your body will begin to eat itself if it
feels like you're trying to hold
the world up on your own shoulders by
yourself
and you're gonna have to get used to
saying no to your family meaning
i gotta go hang out with my buddies i
need an hour and a half to go work out
today
i need an hour to go to lunch by myself
and saying no to your loved ones in that
capacity gives you
the strength and fortitude and
foundation to then do the caretaking
that you need on the back end
and this is going to be a day to day to
day-to-day practice and i both
i both love and hate this for you
because i do understand man you really
made a life shift you did a four-year
apprenticeship on top of school
you said man i'm gonna get out of debt
i'm gonna do these things i got these
plans and then life happened and it
sucks
i hate that for you but what i love
for you is you went meaning makings you
went looking for meaning
through going to school getting a plan
doing
you know dave ramsey's get out of debt
plan you went looking for meaning and
now meaning is slapping you upside the
face
you get the honor yeah i think that's a
very polite way of putting it well you
get to honor and take care of your
sister
you get the honor to take care of your
mom and it is not fun
don't hear me say this is not gonna make
you happy it's gonna make you joyful
because it's right
and i'm proud of you
i think a cornerstone of every day of
your life needs to have
go to walmart for like nine bucks and
buy a little
journal get a yellow pad for 99 cents
buy something and every day of your life
start with
five gratitudes here's what i'm grateful
for
and then underneath that right here's
what's really hard about today
and then write your gratitudes again
just make a hard hard thing sandwich
around gratitudes you're not gonna lie
to yourself of course this stuff's hard
of course you wanna be doing other
things
you got a few more months on this and
hey listen don't beat yourself over
up over guilt we do that all the time
your feelings are your feelings man
having to quit something you've worked
really hard at to take care of somebody
sucks it's hard
it's okay to be frustrated by that it's
not okay to bring poison to it
and so saying it's easy is like saying
uh how do you lose weight diet and
exercise
it's simple but it's not easy same here
going from
pessimistic to optimistic is really hard
probably have to turn the news off
completely
probably have to get rid of social media
and start hanging out with real people
start a barbecue club over your house i
don't know i'm just going to make up
stupid stuff and sound like an idiot but
whatever it looks like
you know you got to have relationships
you know you got to take care of your
body
you know you got to really start working
on your thoughts by writing them down
and being intentional about gratitudes
read um there's a couple of books here
there's one called trauma stewardship by
laura
vandernutt lipsky trauma stewardship
there's another one called burnout by
the negative sisters we'll link to them
here in the show notes
read those two books he'll give you some
perspective
on caretaking on trauma on when you find
yourself in a situation that you didn't
plan for and it's really hard
now you're going to get up and keep
going and get up and keep going and get
up and keep going
here's the thing kurt i think you're a
good guy i really do
it was an honor to talk to you man
i don't want to see you poison yourself
don't poison yourself
every day this is dr john delaney we'll
be right back
[Music]
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do in anxiety
or panic strikes like a lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free guided meditation
it's not really a meditation but really
me just walking with you through your
anxiety alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's go to lisa in roseville
california hey lisa what's up
hey dr delany how are you i'm good how
are you
good hey um i first of all just thank
you for what you do and thank you for
guiding people through
just life um i have sort of an
overarching question and then i'm sure
you'll want to
dig a little bit but um
which is probably your job you do that a
lot so it's more of kind of like a
practical relational marital question
but
um i don't know if your assistant told
you but i'm
expecting our second child literally any
day
so are you super super pregnant
oh yeah oh congratulations do you have
any other questions i'm over it pregnant
i
do we do yes my husband and i have a 23
month old daughter
good girl yeah did you just say you're
over it pregnant
yeah yeah i'm at the over it stage um
so i guess my overarching question is
like um
you know i've heard you talk on dave
ramsey's show and kind of allude to it
like you and your wife have lived
through this
yeah so my question is like how do you
successfully balance a very young
marriage
and very young children when there's so
much pressure
to have it all figured out and when
culture tells you
that you just need to live fast um
because yeah and i know that's kind of a
generic question
that's a great question such a good
question
so um yes me and my wife lived through
it and i would say
especially me i only speak for myself
i didn't do a very good job of this and
so what i'm able to do now is in
retrospect
look back and say man here's what would
have really helped
and as i've talked to
folks experiencing what you're walking
through um
able to they're they're saying oh this
is so so helpful so i think your
question is remarkable and yes i've
lived it i don't know anybody who's got
who's had kids who hasn't lived through
this
so um i'm gonna rattle this off top of
my head here
the first thing i think you nailed it
it's expectations
and here's the two expectations that i
see people get tripped up on
number one is that having a kid
having a second kid having two kids
under two
we just need to get to x y or z and then
we can get our old life back
the old life where we could have sex
whenever we wanted to wherever we wanted
to we could just pack up on a weekend
and go somewhere
we could just run to the movies we don't
we don't have a great um
what's the right way to sit that's
that's just that that
life is over and pretty much yeah
and here's the thing it's okay that it's
over
and what we don't do is we don't we
aren't honest with ourselves with a
period at the end of that sentence and
say
so now what's it going to look like and
somehow we think that
putting sex on the calendar is less than
just doing it anywhere we think that
planning for a trip this weekend is
different or worse than
and it's not it's just different so
coming back to the expectations part
understanding that dude you've been down
this road
you're about to go through it again
right
right and it's just gonna be more fun
because you got a two-year-old that
you're gonna have to
navigate as well really preface a wild
two-year-old but yes
no she's she's awesome of course she is
but she is not gonna take kindly to her
jungle gym is now being shared
right right not cool so now we're back
in it
and it's going to take high
intentionality with you and your husband
that's right that's at the end of the
day it's going to be all sitting down
saying what does this week look like
how are you how am i and being
honest here's the one thing that most
couples don't do until
things are on the brink they don't let
their needs be heard
i need this from you i don't because we
think i don't want to burden them well i
haven't done this he
he's going to think i don't want to
bother her we have to be at a place
relationally where we can let our needs
be heard
and give somebody else permission to say
i can't meet that need for you right now
or i will i'm going to do that but it's
going to cost me this
just being able to speak to one another
and all that comes back to his
intentionality and expectations
right yeah and that kind of piggybacks
off what some people have told me is
that you know you can
especially because i mean my husband and
i have been through a lot i
i got married a little bit later and
then like boom two months later we had
my
you know i got pregnant with my daughter
and life happened
and so neither of these have really been
planned
pregnancies and in a perfect world like
we plan our life we have the materials
we have the finances we have everything
in order
but we know that's not how it happens so
i guess
a little bit of a struggle that i have
now is
that you know when my daughter was about
a year old um
my husband kind of made it very clear he
was like i don't want any more kids
and so this pregnancy i think
men can be different you know he's prior
service army
he did two tours in iraq um
he is a recovering alcoholic um
and so i have felt some resentment and
despondency on his part
and so that's where i'm at right now
where i'm like oh man like
you know but but at the same time i'm
like you know what it's
both of our responsibilities this is
what we signed up for that's right so
did you call it out
well yeah um no you didn't
no you didn't i mean i pretty much i did
but like
you know hey you don't pretty much sit
down with a tutor veteran
who's also a recovering addict and sort
of
you have that conversation or you don't
right
we do but yeah and so that's where i'm
at where i'm like okay
like you know when you get married you
support one another
and you raise your kids together i just
don't want
you know this child to be like an added
stress like oh like is he going to go
back to drinking what are you talking
about of course it's going to be an
added stress it's a new human yeah
yeah yes it is so here's what you got to
do
yeah you got to recognize two things
number one
everybody has permission and i don't
care what anybody says
you're allowed to go oh crap we have
another kid
you're allowed to not be super excited
about it you're allowed to not like that
kid sometimes
you always got to love them and you
always got to show up but you don't have
to like it right
yeah you can not fill in the blank
it doesn't have to be all sunshine and
rainbows and in fact it won't and that
comes back to expectations
we think it's supposed to complete us
and then we have
no psychology for when it doesn't right
right just i just have to just
call this out you said uh
we had decided this is going to be our
last kid
there's like super a way to do to decide
that and you all didn't
we did it we absolutely did it and
that's why it's like you know it's our
responsibility and i know that he's
gonna shoulder it because that's his
personality but
you know i i agree with you that the
expectations are probably
um something that i need to think more
about and be more mindful of
and so be aware create a space where he
feels safe to say what's going on in his
heart and mind in his house
yeah and that comes from you going first
and saying i'm really scared about this
baby
i'm scared that this baby's gonna push
you over the edge
and so early on i said there was two
things one it's expectations here's the
second thing
you have to have to have to both of you
take care of
your mental health your physical health
your spiritual health your
relational health together and that
means being
really gracious with each other about i
need to go for a walk
i gotta sleep i need to
go work out we cannot keep eating donuts
and
whoppers we gotta you know be
intentional about our health whatever
that looks like for y'all
gotta go see a counselor you gotta be
hyper intentional about those things
so that when those stressors come you've
got a foundation to deal with them
right most couples think that this stuff
just quote unquote happens
and that's how you wake up and suddenly
you are
way far apart from your spouse way
further apart than when you started
you both have gained 50 pounds you both
don't like the way you feel the way you
look the way
the other person is treating you and
that's a recipe for disaster so the
intentionality starts really early
does that make sense so you're saying
just really like nurture your
relationship your marriage relationship
make sure that's healthy too and so that
way you can be a good parent because
that's kind of what i've been told is
that people can get
so caught up in raising kids and like
doing what life
that like they neglect their
relationship with each other and that's
where you don't want to end up is like
in a place where
you haven't fostered and nurtured your
marital relationship and then
you're like oh shoot like i don't even
know this person i haven't communicated
so
yeah no that makes total sense the
greatest gift you can give your children
is a really healthy wonderful marriage
yeah that's the greatest gift and the
way to have a healthy
wonderful marriage is to people who are
highly intentional about working through
conflict
doing the things they need to do to keep
each other healthy and themselves
healthy
always coming back to the well and
talking and always coming back to well
and forgiving and being kind and giving
each other a space to talk
all that stuff's really important and
hey listen
you're like gonna have a baby at any
minute
yeah you can think about all this stuff
later
right you're about to you're
[Applause]
you're i'm trying to think of a non-rude
way to say this you're about to
focus on the now like don't stop like
trying to project into the future of
like what ifs what if what if
like every yes everything about
in in the world is about to change
everything and here's the thing yeah you
know what i would love to
do i would really love for you guys to
get 30 days in
and i want you both to call me back
yeah he actually wanted to be on the
call and i was like yes i want someone
to pry information out of you because
it's like so here's the thing in 30 days
after this baby's born
and you'll have a 24 year old climbing
all over you
you haven't slept he is just pacing
around the house
thinking i don't know i think ramadi is
a little bit less chaotic than my
current house
and you are trying to figure out what to
do with this new kid because you think
you got it figured out and this new kid
is going to be totally different
then y'all call me back and i'll walk
alongside each of you as you'll figure
out okay you're 30 days in
to a pregnancy that wasn't planned but
it wasn't not planned it was kind of
planned
if you're not planning not planning your
your planning is how you say that if
you're not not planning your your
straight up planning
man but hey enjoy it you're about to go
through one of the most miraculous
events
ever he's gonna look at that baby he's
gonna be all in
and if he looks at that baby and he's
not all in he's gonna have to be all in
anyway
and then give me a shout back but y'all
are in it be present for this don't be
thinking down the road on this one this
is gonna be awesome
all right let's go to marie in detroit
hey marie what's going on
hey how are you dr d i'm good how are
you
doing okay i'm kind of sleep deprived so
just bear with me
we have
oh you're super sleep deprived yeah
how about this i have a great idea how
about don't even ask a question you can
just put your head down and just sleep
for 10 minutes and we'll just have
silence on the podcast
that sounds great all right go ahead
what's up
okay so okay we kind of have an
interesting situation here so we have
five kids
our oldest is eight he is adopted
from foster care um and he has some
pretty severe
mental illness and like abuse in his
past
um so actually at this point he's not
even living in our homes
due to the severity of his behaviors and
this has just been like
super difficult for our family for me
and my husband
um and we're just kind of grieving that
he's not here
and my question is like my husband and i
are not grieving the same yeah
and it's been really difficult on our
marriage
so i guess we're just looking for some
advice on like
the mismatched grief and just how to
like navigate yeah that's awesome
thanks for that question um so you got
five kids eight and under
yeah and one of them is he in a home now
yeah he is okay um was he violent
hurting himself was he okay yeah yeah
and are your other four kids are they
biological they're adopted too
um they're biological okay so you
adopted
who came first what was the order yeah
we adopted first
okay um and so when you say grief is
mismatched that's a super
common challenge um but before we get
into that i just want
you to exhale for a second and you live
in a really
really chaotic home and that's okay
but i want you to give you and your
husband some grace right now because
what feels like
is channeled towards grieving
differently is probably both of you all
responding to chaos differently
you got five kids under eight or eight
and under
that's a hurricane i got two and i don't
even know what day it is
yeah right that's a lot a lot a lot did
y'all plan all five of these
yeah we did we did we just like always
wanted to have a big family
awesome um and yeah it's just been
tricky as the oldest one his
behaviors have just kind of gotten more
and more severe he's gotten older and
so one day and we were like oh man
walk me through how y'all are grieving
differently
um i mean honestly for me like i'm just
being really vulnerable i've been like
devastated some days i can't
get out of bed it's like really down and
my husband kind of just acted like he
just kind of had to be the rock
so he's just like trucking along doing
life
and i think it's just tricky because i'm
like
are you sad are you okay like you know i
don't know we just i feel like we're
just on different levels right now
um so yeah um
so are you resenting the fact that he
can get out of bed
and i'm not i'm not saying that the mean
way i'm saying that in the is this does
it feel like he doesn't care as much as
you do that you lost your son
maybe uh yeah maybe is he frustrated
with you that he just wants you to snap
out of it let's get to it we got four
other kids around here we got to get up
and going
no definitely not no he's like amazing
and it's like you do whatever you need
to do i'm here to support you
you know i'm here for you so so let me
promise you this
your husband's heartbroken too
and he may look at a situation where
he's got a
wife that he loves with a newborn and
like he said he had to go into rock mode
to make sure the bills are getting paid
and kids are getting fed
and that's okay but it sounds like you
need to give him space to grieve
and some people just
don't fall apart i do i'm somebody that
needs some time
some people aren't they just don't and
some people fall apart to where they
they fall apart fall apart right
have y'all sit down and talk to each
other about the grief
yeah i mean we've tried and he decides
that he feels like okay and he just
i think he's more at peace with the
decision okay than
i am yeah
so i want to ask you a hard question
that's to a sleep-deprived mother of a
newborn which is really not cool
um how would you like him to be grieving
differently
what would make you feel like he's
grieving the right way
i don't know i i guess i just
i don't know i don't know what it would
look like but maybe just be like
more i i guess
what i don't like about it is it makes
me feel very distant from him because i
feel like
we're not in unison on it and
maybe that's the hardest part like i
want to feel like we're kind of
conquering it together
and it says it feels like i'm kind of in
the valley and he's
on the hill like hey you're going to be
okay
yeah does that make sense yeah
um so the way i would reframe it
is you are in it together both of you
lost your son man
and y'all were trying to do the really
noble and remarkable thing through
adoption
and it's hard
hard hard hard um you're super in it
together
what i'd love for you to do is to paint
a picture of what you think his grief
should look like
and what your grief feels like and let
him do the same thing
and just because it doesn't look the
same doesn't mean you're not together
my guess is you're much more if you
remember back to the very first
biological kid you had at seven months i
don't know any couple that feels totally
in sync together relationally
right that's just a season of distance
and so expect that and i don't want you
to take what's happening with that seven
month old and
lay it on top of what's happening with
your son right
those may be two separate processes you
may be healing
man your body still is not yours and
then your husband's running around but
dude i think you're really close into
this together
when you say you feel distant what does
that mean
um i think i feel
i don't know maybe like guilty that i'm
struggling so much and that like he can
be so
okay there it is right there
it's not about him this is about you
yeah dude i didn't even have to say it
that makes my heart feel good way to go
you're way down the road marie
your grief gets to be your grief
and it sounds like you got a pretty
remarkable guy standing by you saying
you grieve however you need to grieve
is that fair yeah oh yeah it is
is he trying to solve you all the time
and fix stuff or is he just letting you
be
no he's he's amazing he's just like i i
got the kids i got dinner
you do what you need to do i'm here for
you he's amazing
okay so here's what i want you to do
you've raised five
and grown four
oh you for the first time probably in a
long time put both of your shoulders
down
and just relax into that dude's arms
you get to grieve however you need to
grieve
okay you are worth grieving
do you believe that yeah
like i said i think i feel guilty
because you know we afford the little
ones that need us and
i still feel guilty that i couldn't help
our older son
stay in our home you know and there's
there's just a lot it's a
hard situation yeah you got to put that
guilt brick down
yeah will you do me a huge favor
in the evenings before you go to bed and
if your husband would do this with you
it'd be awesome
i want you to write down some of those
feelings actually write them all down
they'll be about 10 or 15. it'll take
about 10 minutes to do this but write
them down
i'll let my son down
i didn't whatever today i was a pretty
good mom today
i was a pretty good wife today i want
you to write those feelings down
and then with your husband i want you
all to mine those for evidence
and i want you to say i'm out loud and
look them in the eye when you say them
and say
tell me if this is true or false
and all you're doing is you are feeling
those feelings you're allowed to feel
them they're real
you can't deny them you can't depress
them down
but also you've got to begin to learn to
not let them run your life because some
of them aren't true
you didn't fail a son your son in fact
you're continuing to take care of him
you're not failing your two-year-old by
grieving you're not feeling your
four-year-old by grieving you're not
feeling your seven-month-old by grieving
you're not failing your husband by
grieving okay
but you're gonna need him to look in the
eye and smile and say nope
i love you okay
okay you promise
yeah i do excellent marie you're a rock
star mom
he's lucky to have you and
man i can't even wrap my head around
what it'd be like to lose a kid
they have to send the child away because
they were violent in my home they
weren't safe
heartbreaking should have done this i
could have done that man
if you get to a place where you can't
get out of bed
where the weight and the heaviness just
gets heavier and heavier and heavier
please please reach out to your doctor
reach out to a counselor in your
community go get
some external support there okay
but you get to grieve how you grieve
you have permission to grieve thank you
so much marie
all right as you wrap up today's show
james you're going to like him man
you're going to like him eventually
i am america in the internet
i'm not a wilco fan i'm just not
i've heard jeff tweedy's a great writer
i haven't read his lyrics and all that
blob whatever but james brought me a
clutch one which one do you think
they're both about animals
flying ones at that let's go with muzzle
of beasts muzzle of bees
james child's favorite song of all time
that's not what i said and it goes like
this james's favorite song
ever written and it goes like this what
record is this off of
this is off of a ghost is born a ghost
is ooh that is a good title
i'm not gonna give you that one offie a
ghost is born title james child's
favorite song he actually named his two
kids jeff and tweety
goes like this there's a random painted
highway and a muzzle of bees my sleeves
have come unstitched from climbing your
tree
i don't know what that means but that is
a good poetry right there when dogs
laugh some say they're barking
i don't think they're mean some people
get so frightened of the fences in
between
the sun gets passed from tree to tree
silently then back to me
dude this is making me a wilco fan man
with the breeze blown through pushed
back against the sea
finally back to me i'm assuming you got
my message on your machine i'm assuming
you love me but you know what that means
the sun gets passed from sea to sea
silently and back to me
the breeze blown through pushed up above
the leaves
debris is blowing through my head upon
your knee
james challenge i'm going to give you
that one that's a good system right
there that's that's strong quite strong
this has been the dr john alone show
[Music]
you